- This is how we all dress over there now.
(audience laughing)
What would you like a rap about?
Don't laugh, this is your thinking time.
(audience laughing)
- [Man] Brains.
- Brains?
(audience laughing)
Is that what you said?
- [Man] Yes.
- As in Cerebella, not
the Welsh beer brand?
(audience laughing)
- [Man] Yes.
- Cool. Good.
Just in case we've got
any taffies in, I dunno.
Brains. What about brains?
What interests you about brains?
It's kind of meta that
your brain was like,
"Make it rap about me."
(audience laughing)
Cool, egotistical brains.
Let's come to this side of the room.
Ah, you guys weren't ready.
You thought you had all the time there.
It's like when the teachers like,
"We're gonna do the test in
reverse alphabetical order."
Was that just my teachers? Okay.
(audience laughing)
I was Turner, so I hated that.
Yeah. People against
the wall so far, we got
- [Woman] Mr. PG!
- PG?
- [Woman] Mr PG.
- Oh, Mr. PG.
Well, in doing press for this show,
I rapped about Mr. PG on the radio,
and I don't rap about the
same suggestion twice, so.
"Oh, we wanted you to
rap about our fucking
freakish clown who stands outside this."
(audience laughing)
The guy was like, "Hey,
would you do rap up Mr. PG?"
I was like, "Oh, I'll just
look him up on Wikipedia."
He's like, "You don't wanna do that.
You will not sleep again."
(audience laughing)
So I can't take Mr. PG,
'cause I don't ever do the same rap twice.
So I need something fresh and new.
- [Man 2] Austin Powers.
- Austin Powers? That's racist, man.
You just saw me.
Austin Powers, okay.
Austin Powers, egotistical brains.
That wasn't from that
section against the wall.
So, section against the wall,
you still gotta hit me with one.
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] Snowstorm.
- You say snowstorm?
Great ventriloquism
people against the wall.
(audience laughing)
Snowstorm, ventriloquism,
Austin Powers, egotistical brains.
Right, we got the middle of the room.
This is the hub. This
is the big old bunch.
So if you are on this side
of the middle of the room,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Man 2] A Viking who's
self-conscious about his boat size.
(approval hum)
(audience laughing)
- That's what I like. That's what I like.
(audience cheers)
A Viking who is self-conscious
about his boat size.
Yeah, it's funny,
'cause really we're
thinking about his penis.
(audience laughing)
And now people over here.
I know technically we
got one from down here,
but maybe we come over
to the back on this side.
What do you guys want a rap about?
- [Man 3] Condoms.
- [Man 4] The inner workings
of a pulp mill.
- Okay. So there were two.
One of them immediately
bailed out when they heard
the other person saying the
inner workings of a pulp mill.
(audience laughing)
Which is a great suggestion.
But what was the one that
you kind of was about to say
and didn't get to say?
- [Man 3] Condoms.
- Okay, yeah.
It's worse, isn't it?
(audience laughing)
So let's recap this. Let's recap.
We've got brains and they're egotistical.
We've got snowstorm and
maybe Ventriloquism in there.
We've got Austin Powers,
the inner workings of a pulp mill,
and a Viking self conscious
about his boat size,
and not condoms, so.
(audience laughing)
This, lovely people, the
Prince George Playhouse,
I'm sure is the first time
this illustrious venue
has ever seen a British man freestyle rap,
and depending on how this
goes, maybe the last time
it's ever seen a British
man freestyle rap.
We'll go with the Number B.
Yeah? Let's use that B.
I feel like these suggestions fit that.
Let's drop that beat
and let's have some fun.
(rap beat)
Oh yeah, I feel this.
You guys feel this?
(audience cheers)
Yeah? But I mean like, you guys feel this?
Yeah, you feel it.
"Hell yeah" from my Austin
Powers man down here.
That's it.
He's flicking me the V's like that.
That's offensive in my country, you know?
That's basically like this.
But you were like, "nah, cool."
I like it. It's gonna be fucking sick.
Just beats too long on the
intro first, don't worry.
♪ Give the V sign, shouting out peace ♪
♪ Austin Power on the
screen, look at those teeth ♪
♪ Michael Myers, I know
he's from North America ♪
♪ He's kind of sexy, you spy
him with the chest hair ♪
♪ You best beware ♪
♪ Dr. Evil and Mini Me ♪
♪ One's of them's tall ♪
♪ One's kinda less equal with the size ♪
♪ He's walking in the room like ♪
♪ "Oh shagalicious baby, boom, boom" ♪
♪ Liz Hurley with the massive breasts ♪
♪ If he did this today
he'd be branded a pest ♪
♪ Basically section E harassing ♪
♪ Solving all the crime while
he's doing grab ass-ing ♪
♪ But that's okay ♪
♪ I don't pour scorn ♪
♪ On spies like Austin
Powers or Jason Borne ♪
♪ I'm kinda blinded to the skill ♪
♪ Like I'm in a snowstorm ♪
♪ Cold outside, so I want to get warm ♪
♪ Going inside, make a
fire with the twigs ♪
♪ Looking at my dummy,
'cause I'm a ventriloquist ♪
♪ I'm like, oh, off we go ♪
♪ Make your mouth down low
when outside it snows ♪
♪ Are we gonna get snowed in ♪
♪ You agree ♪
♪ My little ventriloquist
dummy, I can see ♪
♪ What's it based on ♪
♪ Well easily ♪
♪ We know the weird statue of Mr. PG ♪
♪ With his weird little hat,
septic tack on his body ♪
♪ I be like, "yes, I wish to thank" ♪
♪ He's the mascot ♪
♪ He's the symbol of your town ♪
♪ If a snowstorm came and blew him down ♪
♪ You would gather all around ♪
♪ You would get a little census ♪
♪ Saying, "please sign this" ♪
♪ We erect this back up ♪
♪ Make him 10 feet tall ♪
♪ Talk about our Viking
who's ever so small ♪
♪ In the boat region ♪
♪ I'm not saying nethers ♪
♪ He be from Norway, getting it together ♪
♪ In the winter time ♪
♪ Off to some village ♪
♪ To find some ladies
to rape and pillage ♪
♪ And it's okay to rape,
as long as you pillage ♪
♪ Isn't that weird, yeah ♪
♪ There's some spillage on a
ship 'cause the poop deck ♪
♪ Isn't that large ♪
♪ The big Viking comes
in who's in charge ♪
♪ Like, "yeah son, you
need to get a longer one ♪
♪ Otherwise your boat
won't fit in a condom" ♪
♪ Wait, that makes really no sense ♪
♪ I see the dragon's head
and I start to get tense ♪
♪ And I'm mentioning this, hard to weave ♪
♪ Coming over here with an English beat ♪
♪ Is the microphone cable busting now ♪
♪ That's okay ♪
♪ Acapella, when I scream and shout ♪
♪ Then the Viking, not to his liking ♪
♪ We can see this ♪
♪ Scream at the people,
he's got a small penis ♪
♪ He said "ah, not my cord" ♪
♪ Getting this with the
cable barely on the floor ♪
♪ So cracker lady, is there another mic ♪
♪ Yeah, we'll just keep going ♪
♪ Keep blowing tonight ♪
♪ Only one more thing, got to spill ♪
♪ Let me talk about the inner
workings of a pulp mill ♪
♪ Wait, one sec, forgot it again ♪
♪ I got reminded of my egotistical brain ♪
♪ He's like, "Chris, you
just skip me, move past ♪
♪ Do the pulp mill first
save the best to last" ♪
♪ I'm like, "Okay, so many
rhymes I will tell 'em ♪
♪ Make you know the paper
then use my cerebellum" ♪
♪ I'm writing it down ♪
♪ We can all see ♪
♪ Is Mr. PG like a model of trees ♪
♪ 'Cause we're cutting 'em
down with the chainsaw ♪
♪ I get it over there ♪
♪ Put it on the mill's floor ♪
♪ I start mixing it round ♪
♪ In the chipper it goes ♪
♪ It's like the death
at the end of Fargo ♪
♪ I know that's North
Dakota, not in your country ♪
♪ But if you want a little
bit of pulp come to me ♪
♪ I can help you ♪
♪ The paper friction ♪
♪ The type of pulp like is Pulp Fiction ♪
♪ But back here, over to the brain ♪
♪ Once you've had one, you'll
never feel the same again ♪
♪ People say "brain,
yes, I really like you" ♪
♪ And I do why ♪
♪ 'Cause I got the high IQ ♪
♪ It's ever so good ♪
♪ It'd be rocking my world ♪
♪ I got that nice pink
fleshy thing in my skull ♪
♪ There we go ♪
♪ People say "the brain might be crap" ♪
♪ But it's the thing that's
bringing you the freestyle rap ♪
Boom.
(audience cheering)